Speaker 1: I got emails over the weekend, David.
You wouldn't dare cover the investigation into
Congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez. It
doesn't fit your narrative to talk about the
fact that she's under ethics investigation. Come
on, guys. Come on. You all know I do not care
about political party or these elected officials
as people. And what I mean by that is it's not
like I'm saying I don't I don't care if they get
hit by a car. No, that's not it. What I mean is
the cult of personality that forms around so many
elected officials. I just don't care about it.
These are just people. They are all. They're all
they. They do good. They do bad. They have good
ideas. They have ideas I don't care for. AOC
is just another person, that's all. And so I
would have no reason to hide from you that AOC
is the subject of a House ethics investigation.
That's absolutely the case that is going on,
and it has been under a Democratic House.
That's happening. The Guardian reports AOC
is subject of House ethics investigation.
Spokesperson is confident undisclosed
matter, quote, will be dismissed.
The Democratic acting chair, Susan Wild and
acting ranking member Michael Guest released
a statement on Wednesday. They say the matter
regarding AOC was transmitted to the committee
by the Office of Congressional Ethics on 23 June.
The subject was not revealed. The committee said
the mere fact of a referral or an extension and
the mandatory disclosure of such an extension
and the name and subject of the subject of the
matter does not itself indicate a violation has
occurred. What they're saying is. You're innocent
until proven guilty. There is an investigation,
but that doesn't mean that any violation
has taken place. The House Ethics Committee
said it would announce its course of action
after the new Congress convenes in January.
That's what's going on. Now, in September of 2021,
the American Accountability Foundation filed an
ethics complaint against her for, quote, accepting
an impermissible gift to attend the Met gala.
The event was a $35,000 a ticket event. That's
where she wore the tax, the rich dress. A
spokesperson said she was invited as a guest
of the Met and didn't get to keep the dress.
The question is whether that may have violated the
ethics rules because even though she was a guest,
someone paid for the ticket and the $35,000
ticket is worth more than the maximum donation,
so that there may be something there.
Now. When something like this happens,
what should the left do? For the most part, the
left does what it should do. If you think back to
Anthony Weiner, you know the right loves to say,
oh, the left is they have these double standards.
They want to go after everyone on the right, but
then they want to protect Hunter Biden or they
were defending Anthony Wiener or they think that
an investigation into AOC is by definition wrong
because she's the darling of the left. I don't
see anyone doing that stuff. Think back to the
Anthony Weiner circumstances. My view on Anthony
Weiner was skilled politician, great speaker,
doesn't deserve any particular protection for the
things he is accused of. And he did things wrong
and he has to suffer the consequences. With Al
Franken, remember the bad joke and the picture
with Al Franken that subsequently left to him
led to him resigning from the Senate Democrats.
If they could be criticized for anything on that
were too quick to demand a resignation too quick,
when in the end it seemed like it was more of
a bad joke and misunderstanding than anything
approximating the things that the right has done
and has been accused of. Hunter Biden Listen,
I don't know anyone saying Hunter Biden must
be protected. There is obviously a political
bias going on when it comes to the targeting of
Hunter Biden. There is an attempt to conflate
Hunter Biden with Joe Biden. When Hunter has
nothing to do with the Biden administration,
there is no proof that the big guy that is
referenced in the infamous emails is Joe Biden.
There's this. It's obviously grasping at straws
because they have nothing. But I and everybody I'm
seeing on the left says Hunter Biden did something
wrong, then investigate him and indict him if it's
a crime and convict him if the evidence is there.
Who cares? Nobody's defending him. And similarly,
if AOC did something wrong, there should be an
investigation. And if it turns out that indeed she
did do something wrong, there should be whatever
punishment is appropriate. We just can't have it
be partizan witch hunts. That's the concern. And
that's why with Hunter Biden, when he clearly has
nothing to do with the Biden administration,
the desire to turn the next Congress into the
Congress that will impeach Biden for things we
don't even really know and investigate Hunter
Biden for the full two years. That's when it gets
disgusting and concerning. So that's where we are.
Let's figure out what AOC did, if anything.
If she should be fined, then let's find her.
That's it. But let's make sure that we're doing
it equally and that we're not turning this into
a partizan witch hunt. We're going to take
a quick break and be right back after this